if there's one thing that NSA values its
secrecy it has been allowed to operate
in ways that aren't always consistent
with public's understanding of the laws
the Constitution or even other parts of
the executive branch's interpretation of
the law these programs are moving along
in the ash rack I am Zach Weiss Miller
for reason TV i'm here at the Electronic
Frontier Foundation San Francisco
headquarters i'm talking with staff
attorney mark rumbled he's done work on
a lawsuit challenging the right of the
US Department of Justice to keep its
surveillance activities shrouded in
secrecy mark thank you very much for
talking to us thanks the purpose of eff
s lawsuit against the Department of
Justice is to get the details of an
unfavorable ruling that a FISA Court
gave to the Department of Justice
regarding surveillance um when did eff
first filed this lawsuit and what are
the latest developments in the case in
the run-up to the reenactment of the
FISA Amendments Act in 2012 Senator Ron
Wyden pushed the executive branch very
hard to declassify three statements one
of them was that the FISC had held that
some of the executive branch's
surveillance under the FISA Amendments
Act was unconstitutional another was
that the fisc head held that the
surveillance they had conducted had
violated the spirit of the law and then
so actually there were only two and then
the executive made him include that the
Fisk had correct or that the executive
branch had corrected those just to
clarify for our viewers the Fisk is the
FISA Court the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court it's a court
established by statute that hears
government applications for the conduct
electronic surveillance and national
security cases so with those public
statements made that was the first time
that the public had had known that the
government was conducting surveillance
that had been determined to be
unconstitutional we filed a Freedom of
Information Act request
with the executive branch for that
opinion the executive branch came back
said it's classified we can't disclose
it so we suit because it's our position
and it's it's it's actually the
executive branch is positioned to that
they can't classify information just to
conceal violations of law and it's
interesting because you are saying you
wouldn't even have known that it was
being concealed if not for Senator Wyden
you know saying something about it and
Senator one couldn't even say anything
about it until it was cleared by the
executive branch to say so senator Wyden
I imagined pushed very hard to have that
information disclosed and thankfully it
was so we filed suit in the district
court in Washington DC and the
government came back with a with a
pretty strange argument in addition to
saying it was classified their argument
was their hands were tied because of the
judiciary and it essentially was the
executive branch trying to point the
finger at another branch of government
saying oh we'd love to disclose this
unconstitutional surveillance but we
can't because of the judiciary the FISC
ended up ruling in your favor which I
believe was the first time ever ruling
in favor of non government entity that
we know about that don't know about
right because there's you know there's
all these layers that ruling came out
after the revelations that Edward
Snowden leaked came out it's hard to
imagine that that's coincidental timing
I'm not surprised by the fist decision
because the government's argument was it
was crazy and I think the fish was right
to reject it and to reject it quickly
the same time I think judges on the
court don't exist in a vacuum i think
they were hearing a lot of the criticism
they were receiving in the press and you
know seeing how the the order was being
construed in the public and i think that
may have contributed to it but i
certainly think or at least i hope that
would have held in our favor
regardless so at this point we know that
the fisc ruled against the Department of
Justice regarding something to do with
section 702 right that's about all we
know right well so we know it had to do
with the minimization procedures okay so
basically the procedures the government
uses to ensure that US person
information isn't swept up and their
surveillance that they're doing the FISC
held that those procedures were
unconstitutional that they've that they
violated the Fourth Amendment does that
do these give us any clues as to what
might be going on what it is that the
Department of Justice was doing that the
FISA Court actually ruled against them
and said this is in violation of the
conservation I don't want to speculate
because there are a number of
possibilities about what they could have
been doing that was that was
unconstitutional but I think at the very
least we know that it involved if not
citizens it involved you know legal
residence within the United States and
it involved their communications in some
way what has the Department of Justice's
response been so far our are those
papers forthcoming no response so far we
have we have a status report in District
Court in Washington DC due july first so
hopefully we'll find out more then but
it's our position and based on their
previous filings that they will have to
release at least part of the opinion now
have the leaks given you a momentum or
how they affected all of this it's
raised public is public awareness about
its raised congressional awareness about
it a lot of members of Congress I don't
think we're briefed on how these
programs were being used you know the
disclosures also help our cases right so
in the 215 FOIA case they had claimed
that they couldn't disclose anything
because it was all classified top secret
we we were just asking for legal
interpretation we were looking for like
a legal memo that says you know this is
how we interpret our
and this is how broad it is or how
narrow it is and they said they couldn't
release it it was top secret the fact
that you have to navigate all these
layers of secrecy just to get the most
basic bit of information that you
wouldn't have even known that you should
start navigating unless one senator
hadn't mentioned it in the first place
what are kind of the first reforms that
you think we need to enact to kind of
alleviate that problem what eff is
pushing for is a full public and public
that's the critical element here is a
full public debate about these
surveillance programs about the scope of
the government's authority the
government has been going about the
process in the wrong way right they've
been doing things behind closed doors
and then when they get caught trying to
brief members of Congress trying to
breathe the judiciary but this time
around we need to start with the full
public debate then figure out what
reforms are appropriate figure out what
you know what surveillance the American
public is comfortable with for those
people who you know care about privacy
and care about government surveillance
and want to do something about it and
want to help eff push back against it
what would your advice be we have a
petition that we would welcome more more
signatures on it's a stop watching that
us we encourage people to call to email
to do whatever just to be to be angry
about this type of invasive surveillance
marc rhima thank you very much for
talking to us Thanks thank you
you